-Our next guest is
a talented actor you know from
films such as "An Education,"
"Shattered Glass," and "Jackie."
He's currently starring
in the fantastic
limited series "Dopesick."
The series finale will be
streaming tomorrow on Hulu.
Let's take a look.
-You guys holding out on me?
-Um...
Well, it's still very early,
but we've begun looking at
something that could be big.
-What are we talking about?
-OxyContin.
-Specifically, Purdue Pharma
is the company that makes it.
They've been marketing the drug
and pushing it on doctors
as something that's nonaddictive
when it clearly is.
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Peter Sarsgaard,
everybody.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome back.
-Thank you.
-It's so nice to see you.
-It's nice to be back
with a bunch of people.
-Yeah. Right? People are great.
-All in a little space
like this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I like people.
-We haven't seen each other
for years.
-You're not going to
remember this,
but I think it was in 2015,
you know,
the race in Chilmark
down Middle Road.
-Yep, this is a 5K.
-It's a 5K.
-5K in Martha's Vineyard.
-And I used to be a decent
runner before I turned 50.
-I remember that about you.
-Yeah.
Are you aware that
we raced each another?
-No.
-You're not aware of that.
[ Laughter ]
So, at the start,
I didn't realize you were
a runner at the time.
And I was like
a pretty decent runner.
So I line up, and you're like --
We're pretty close -- I don't
know why you didn't see me.
I really saw you.
[ Laughter ]
You're kind of like over there
and I think, like, "Right.
I'm just going to --
That's my mark, you know?"
[ Laughter ]
By the end of this race --
It's a road that's --
It's basically straight
the whole way,
so you can see a quarter a mile
ahead of you,
which is nice, and that way,
I could see you finish.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Because this guy's real fast.
Are you still really fast?
-I'm not very fast, no.
I still run, but I think
the thing is happening to me
that maybe had happened to you.
[ Laughter ]
I think I'm just
a few years behind you,
is what I'm getting at.
-I understand that.
I'm having trouble sitting right
now, so let's get on with it.
-The most depressing thing that
happened to me one year
when I ran that road race,
where I set a time
that I was aiming to hit.
And then, you know,
they have photos.
My wife took a picture of me
finishing, and I had to crop it
because in front of me finishing
like 50 feet ahead
was like a 9-year-old.
[ Laughter ]
And I'm like sweating,
and it's just like
the happiest 9-year-old.
[ Laughter ]
I want to talk about this show
because it's so wonderful.
But you had
an interesting experience.
Your wife Maggie Gyllenhaal,
a fantastic actor,
has now become --
[ Light applause ]
Yeah, give it up for Maggie.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-A very -- A very accomplished
director.
She has a film coming out
that is getting a great deal
of Oscar buzz that you're in.
But I want to ask about
a short film
you were in called "Penelope."
Because it seems to me
that she gave you a role
that maybe you would only offer
to a husband.
-Right. So, this is right at
the beginning of the pandemic.
I think we shot it
in April of 2020
on our property in Vermont.
And it's -- it feels, you know,
post-apocalyptic sort of thing.
But one of the features
of the show is
that I do make love to a tree.
[ Laughter ]
And it builds up to it
in a very natural way
and it totally makes sense.
[ Laughter ]
-You're not just like a creep
who humps a tree.
-I'm dropping this on you
right now, but, like,
it actually --
you feel for both of us.
[ Laughter ]
But this is on our actual
property that we shot it.
So since then, you know,
I've been back up there,
doing my little chores
and all of that.
Every time I walk past
this tree...
[ Laughter ]
...I have this kind of...
It's like I can't look at
the tree,
the tree can't really look
at me.
[ Laughter ]
So, yeah, but it's really lovely
being directed by your wife.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you think Maggie ever, like,
looks out the window
and sees you looking at the tree
and thinks, "What have I done?"
[ Laughter ]
-Maybe, maybe, maybe.
But, yeah, and then I did this
inc-- We had this
incredible experience on
"The Lost Daughter," where,
again, one of the first films
out in COVID, in August of 2020.
We went to a Greek island called
Spetses, which is incredible.
We all quarantined for 14 days,
and we made this movie
end of September, October,
and incredible, incredi--
I really, truly love
being directed by my wife.
-That's really awesome.
I can't wait to see it.
I've just heard
such incredible things,
and it seemed like
such an incredible cast.
-Absolutely. Olivia Colman
and Dakota Johnson
and Jessie Buckley and Ed Harris
and all these people.
-"Dopesick" --
also an incredible cast.
This is a very --
This is a real story?
-Yeah.
-This is a story you were
familiar with before you did it.
You'd actually done
a documentary
about the opioid crisis.
-Yes.
So, I have someone very close
to me who's really struggled
with this for a very long time.
And so this was back in 2016,
and Norman Lear
and Shonda Rhimes came to me
and said that they were doing
this series called
"America Divided,"
which was about issues
leading up to the election
that maybe voters
should think about.
Now it seems like
very Pollyannaish to think
that issues are why people vote.
[ Laughter ]
But, you know, I noted that
the opioid crisis was not on
the list of things,
and actually, Rosario,
who's in the show,
did one about Flint, Michigan,
and the water crisis.
And so they sent me
to Dayton, Ohio.
And I went on ride-alongs
with police officers.
I hung out with people
who were using --
actively using in front of me.
Family members. Support groups.
Went to the jail and saw users
trying to dry out.
And it actually gave me
a different perspective
on my own personal situation
and had me have a different type
of understanding,
empathy, patience,
all of the things
you're going to need
if you're around somebody
who's going through this.
And so when this show came
along, I was working with Warren
on something else --
Littlefield,
who's the producer of this.
And I was like, "I have to be
a part of that.
I don't care what role it is."
And then they offered me a role
of, like, a decent person.
I assumed they would offer me
the role of, like,
somebody slinging dope.
[ Laughter ]
The fact that I got to play,
like, you know,
a self-righteous, good guy
is awesome.
-You also got to work with
the great Michael Keaton,
who is not only a fantastic
actor, but he was somebody
I've been lucky enough to get
to meet a couple times.
And it was deeply important to
me that Michael Keaton
was a good person,
which he also is.
-He also is, and I think we were
talking about this backstage,
that Michael Keaton actually
never begins or ends a sentence.
-Yeah.
-He only does the middle part.
[ Laughter ]
And we've been doing all this
publicity, and I just --
I just love the way, you know --
he's like, you know,
"And I was -- you know, it's --
I got the Tesla
'cause I'm a knee-jerk --
you know, no one wants to hear
an actor talk about this kind of
stuff, but it's --
you know, I got the little one.
I got just the little --
you know, it's --"
[ Laughter ]
"I don't know."
-[ Laughing ] That's the best.
I'm going to do a one-word
Michael Keaton impression.
-Okay, okay.
-It's Michael Keaton listening
and then saying yes to
what you're asking.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-Oh, my God.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Congrats on the show.
Thank you for being here.
It's always a pleasure.
-Thanks for having me.
-Peter Sarsgaard.
Series finale of "Dopesick"
streaming tomorrow on Hulu.